d'habitude je commence mon pardon je
commence la prédication par mes chers
frères et soeurs en christ alors il ya
beaucoup moins de monde occulte dimanche
matin il faut dire que les sièges des
temples sont beaucoup moins confortable
et aussi le risque d'être ainsi comme
cela de s'endormir
donc lorsque le culte dure longtemps
soit dormir est qu'est ce que j'ai fait
au bon dieu qu'est ce que j'ai fait au
bon dieu
il ya eu le film l'année dernière qu'est
ce qu'on a fait au bon dieu vous mais je
suis sûr que chacun chacune d'entre vous
un jour dans sa vie a dû dire qu'est ce
que j'ai fait au bon dieu
lorsque ça va pas lorsque nous avons des
soucis dans nos vies qu'est ce que j'ai
fait au bon dieu
la vie nous semble à ce moment-là
absurde on voit pas le bout du tunnel
on se considère dans une impasse comment
sortir de cette impasse
on ne sait pas on est dans le fond du
trou c'est impensable peuvent être
professionnel on est licencié on a une
entreprise qui en cessation paiement
qu'en liquidation judiciaire on ne plaît
pas aux patrons et mis au placard
impasse professionnelle mais aussi à les
impasses personnel les impasses
personnel la maladie la mort le chômage
plein d'impasse mais aussi ses seins
parce que nous nous fabriquons nous
mêmes on refuse d'avancer on refuse
d'aller voir là où il ya la lumière au
bout du tunnel non on reste dans notre
cocon parce qu'on a peur d'avancer on se
fabrique vaut 1 passe et puis et puis on
est là cet après midi réunis pour
entendre des speakers parler sur le
thème de la renaissance d intelligence
en tant que théologien ya un terme qui
m'a titillé l'esprit
renaissance la renaissance savez que
vous savez pas je vous parlais un peu de
bible le grec aulnay où est tiré d'un
nouveau testament résurrection c'est
aussi se relever se relever une
renaissance et dans cette bible dans les
évangiles il y a des mots des
expressions qui peuvent marquer qu'ils
peuvent toucher qui peuvent toucher à un
moment donné ou un autre de nos vies je
vais vous parler d'un mot une expression
tout petit mot et fatah et fatah tu veux
dire en araméen
car jésus parlait pas le grec mais
l'araméen et fatah ouvre toi
ouvre toi jésus utilise ce mot là
lorsqu'il guéri ce mot non mais c'est
pas grave lorsqu'il guéri un homme
sourd-muet chez patients des médecins
ici mais la façon de guérir de jésus
était très facile
il prend de la boue qu'il met sur les
yeux
l'homme est il met de la salive de sa
salive sur la langue de cette arme
dark met tout de suite après jésus lui
dit ouvre toi
et c'est le miracle de la guérison mais
plus loin
jésus lui dit va pas par cet ordre
il indique à cet homme qu'il ne doit pas
rester dans son cocon
il est guéri il doit partir il doit
reprendre les chemins de sa vie il doit
exister exister du latin exister riz se
décentrer de soi même pour vivre pour
partir encore et nouveau sur les chemins
de la vie car c'est là la spécificité de
la foi chrétienne est ma vision de la
foi c'est que quelles que soient les
circonstances de la vie
l'homme peut se relever et peut repartir
sur les chemins de la vie avec toutes
les capacités qui lui sont honnis sans
jugement mais avec force il revit ses
possibilités
il revit ces intelligences j'ai
l'impression de faire une prédication
je vais vous donner un petit exemple cet
exemple je parlais chercher bien loin
je vous parlais un peu de moi j'ai fait
un bac g2 les plus anciens d'entre nous
savent que j'ai deux ces techniques
quantitatives de gestion au grand
chênois montbéliard puis je suis parti
on as à quelques centaines de mètres dc
non et puis arrive entre l'année du deug
l'année de licences la mort de ma maman
je fais quand même une année de licence
le nez dans les chaussettes balmoral jeu
quand on a 22 ans perdre une maman c'est
quand même pas facile
et puis je me suis dit je vais tout
arrêter
effectivement j'ai tout arrêté
suis parti travailler dans la grande
maison
les montbéliardais savent que la grande
maison c'est peugeot savais ce que je
faisais j'ai commencé par travailler je
triais les faisceaux électriques pour
les phares arrière de voiture
après j'ai travaillé en chêne travail
enchaîne gta poste
mon rôle c'était de mettre les ceintures
de sécurité arrière les trois ceintures
sur la plage arrière de la voiture de
tester avant ses ceintures de sécurité
je tapais je tirais 6 à ce blocage
pourrait poser comme j'étais à peu près
habile voix j'avais un poste j'ai pris
deux postes avant savez comme ça ça me
faisait un peu de liberté entre deux
voitures
jusqu'au moment où chef de ligne arrivé
moi me dit on poste guéri ton post est
là tu bouges pas de là une petite goutte
de goudron et est tombé sur une ceinture
de sécurité la voiture il fallait
refaire
après j'ai travaillé chez les objets des
f
bref et je fais encore partie de cette
génération qui a fait le service
militaire je devais partir à la re mi et
je cette chance d'être à trèves en
allemagne d'être avec un aumônier
militaire protestant bien sûr c'était le
dernier aumônier de crémines du criminel
de guerre ou des fesses et j'ai changé
pendant dix mois avec cet aumônier est
arrivé au mois d'avril il dit guéri il
faudrait peut-être que tu penses à les
inscrire à la fac si tu veux je suis
parti avec la voiture militaires
habillés en militaires à l'université
enfin la faculté théologie de strasbourg
pour m'inscrire et quand j'ai terminé
j'ai eu terminé mais dis moi et je suis
reparti pour cinq ans en théologie à
strasbourg
je suis passé des livres comptables des
livres de bilan des théories économiques
du dalloz du droit constitutionnel du
droit administratif au gré calibre ou
nouveau testament à la dengue matic à la
pratique la systématique cinq en cinq
ans mais dans ces cinq ans j'ai
redécouvert que on pourrait faire
quelque chose quand se motive en bas on
pouvait s'en sortir qu'on pouvait
trouver le bonheur de vivre
j'ai été ordonné pasteur en 2004 depuis
le jeu suit pasteur de l'inspection
montbéliard de la région est montbéliard
maintenant et il ya quelques années j'ai
retrouvé un de mes anciens profs d'alès
qu'elle a devant moi jean jacques wagner
comme aumônier militaire de gendarmerie
et jean jacques m'a demandé ce que je
faisais là j'ai dit tout simplement fut
devenu pasteur et qu'ils me voyaient
dans ses cours en ami e s de ben voilà
j'étais pasteur et me voilà maintenant
devant vous à discuter grâce à lui
peut-être à vous intéresser un petit peu
à la fois je sais vous allez me dire
banon n'a pas la foi dans la théologie
il y a les choses
l'évocation interne évocation externe
évoque la vocation externe ouija diplômé
e s oui j'ai un dss un master de
théologie protestante ça c'est du
concret c'est de l'externat
mais aussi la vocation interne la fois
la fois ce n'est pas quantifiable
moi je 95% fois et j'ai cinq pour cent
ne se prononcent pas non c'est pas comme
ça à la fois on l'a on l'a pas mais
c'est pas parce qu'on l'a pas qu'on peut
pas renaître dans la ville il ya des
signes de la ville il ya des rencontres
dans la ville il ya des regards échangés
dans la ville il ya des paroles même si
on n'a pas la foi c'est parole ces
regards ces souris vivent peuvent nous
donner le goût de renaître le goût de se
relever le goût de repartir de repartir
à la conquête du monde à la conquête de
sa vie ta renaître c'est aussi se
réconcilier avec soi-même et fatah
ouvre toi et tu pourra renaître
merci